Russia's invasion of Ukraine is into its
16th month moscow's occupied about 18 of
its neighbor and has done so by Smashing
towns and cities using Rockets missiles
and artillery shells
at times its military has fired as many
as 20 000 shells in a single day Little
Wonder then that they're running short
so what to do well they've ramped up
their domestic weapons production and
they've been helped by their few allies
Iran's already supplied drones to Russia
now Sky News can reveal Tehran may be
supplying far more besides
I'm Kamali Melbourne and this is the Sky
News Daily
hi Debs can you hear me okay hi I yes I
can hello how are you I hear you're in
an airport uh departure Lounge well I'm
not even a departure Lounge I'm on a
seat uh in a hall in the airport in
Helsinki and I'm transiting from Estonia
back to London
um I've just been on a trip with our
foreign secretary to Estonia fantastic
in today's episode we speak to our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes who has seen a contract
purportedly drawn up between the Iranian
defense Ministry and a Russian arms firm
it's about the sale of Iranian
ammunition and other military material
to Russia we haven't been able
independently to verify the authenticity
of the document but I've shown it to the
ukrainians I've given it to the British
government and I've spoken to the
foreign secretary about it and he wasn't
able to comment specifically on the
document but he did relay the concern
about how Iran has been assisting Russia
during its war in Ukraine so what kind
of details are in this contract that's
been drawn up who's it between this
contract is between the minutes
of Iran and also a Russian entity called
JSC rozo Boren export which is the
Russian military export entity and it is
dated the 14th of September last year I
understand that that date does coincide
with other reporting about the potential
for this kind of activity in terms of
ammunition sales to be taking place take
us through what kind of Munitions are
being supplied so the contracts for
for Russian weapons different types of
shells different shell sizes for
artillery pieces and for tanks so we're
talking about large bullets really that
could obviously cause really horrendous
damage and the contract is for sort of
it seems to be like sample quantities so
there's like a price list that sets out
the different size of the round
um how many pieces are included and then
the total price so for this one contract
that I've seen
um it all comes in at just over a
million dollars and then I've also seen
this the supplementary section to a
contract and now the the sort of the
identifying number on the main contract
is different by one digit to the
identifying number on the supplementary
part
um so one ends in 60 and one ends in 59.
now A source told me they believe it's
because like around that same time a
number of contracts similar contracts
for different examples of of ammunition
were agreed and so that kind of explains
that discrepancy now this supplement is
interesting because it includes things
like two barrels for a Howitzer
artillery piece and two barrels for a
t-72 tank
um so it's you know when I've shown this
to the ukrainians they've sort of said
it's quite interesting because it gives
an indication perhaps of the kind of
military material that the Russians are
in need of my sources say that they
believe that these were kind of sort of
samples ahead of larger deals being
struck now it's fascinating that it
seems to be this is sort of like a
sampler menu of what you can get if you
fulfill the contract
um and of course at the time that this
contract purports to have been drawn up
there were lots of reporting around that
Russia was running short of ammunition
and those kind of large artillery shells
are exactly the kind of things that the
Russians were using to pound the
Ukrainian cities as they basically put
them under siege before attending an
infantry yeah Russia said itself they've
been trying to Galvanize their own
industrial base to produce more weapons
but they've also been going to their
limited number of allies to try to get
more weapons but it really does
underline how Russia clearly given its
war effort is expending so much
ammunition trying to fight in Ukraine
that their stocks like the Western
stocks are running low Deborah what does
the contract in your reporting tell us
about the way that these weapons got to
Russia from Iran so the contracts
written in English which might seem a
bit strange given it's between Iran and
Russia purportedly but I've been told
that that's not unusual it's actually
quite customary when it comes to
contracts being drawn up by Iran with
another International partner and
obviously English is an international
language so perhaps that shouldn't be a
surprise there are spelling mistakes in
the contract too but again the source
told me that that's also possible to
have to have typos of it does seem a bit
strange that you'd have typos in an
official contract but another person
that I've shown this to also agreed with
that assessment that it was possible to
have spelling mistakes and it has said
that it really does read like a standard
contract so there are formal articles
setting out who the parties are what the
subject of the contract is what the
prices are so like I said the first part
of the contract is valued it just over a
million dollars and then that
supplementary section is valued at it's
just under sort of 750 000 and then it
also talks about the terms and
conditions so the delivery and how it's
going to be taken by plane how it needs
to be be sure that all of the supplies
have the right kind of Customs checks
and permissions it seems that these
first samples were to be flown from the
airport in Tehran to Russia it doesn't
go into more details on that but
obviously in the contract there's
provision for them to be shipped as well
the items that were to be shipped they'd
be going across the Caspian Sea right so
we've reported earlier this year that
Iran had provided large supplies of
ammunition to Russia and these were in
shipments that allegedly happened
Russian cargo ships took these um it was
ammunition for small arms and also for
artillery pieces so regular bullets and
then larger shells for artillery guns
and mortars and sort of rocket launches
and that they yeah they were shipped via
the Caspian Sea that's never been
confirmed by Russia or Iran but if it
ever were to be confirmed then it would
really signal a deepening of the support
from Iran to Russia for this war just
explain why moving arms across the
Caspian Sea into Russia is a much easier
way for them to move weapons than of
course across the Black Sea which we've
brought as NATO member states turkey the
Black Sea itself it's basically within
the range of the war zone in Ukraine so
to try to ship any kind of cargo we're
seeing a lot about the shipping of grain
through the Black Sea e requires a huge
amount of negotiation to make that
passage well geographically it's not the
most direct route to get arms to Ukraine
if that's where this ammunition is
ultimately destined for going across the
Caspian Sea it's a stretch of water that
connects you know directly from Iran to
Russia is a much easier route for them
to take and also much harder for Western
allies to be able to track there has
been reporting and you've done some of
it about concerns that there are other
countries that could also be supplying
the Russians with weapons the US has
said that they believe that China had
been considering providing Military
Support to Russia China has denied that
but China has also not condemned
Russia's actions in Ukraine and has also
been supporting Russia through
non-military Aid were China to decide
that it was going to start actually
actively giving weapons to Russia that
would potentially be a game-changing
moment in terms of ensuring that Russian
stockpiles are replenished much more
quickly I also wonder about those other
non-aligned countries that might well be
supplying weapons I mean countries like
North Korea as well again another Pariah
State there's been reporting that
Russia's been looking at other sort of
former Soviet states that it still has
friendly relations with and which have
you know the same kind of arsenal of
weapons in their stockpiles to to get
weapons from them Russia is under heavy
sanctions from the west and that does
restrict its ability to manufacture new
weapons but Western officials believe
the Russians have been using up
stockpiles of weapons the NATO allies
for example would have long discarded as
being unsafe safe because they're so old
so again it just shows you the level of
risk that Russia seems to be willing to
take with its own soldiers
the Iranian military-industrial complex
they're under sanctioned do they have
the capacity to be reducing Weaponry
that they could then export they do
absolutely have the capacity to export
weapons they've been doing it on an
industrial scale in terms of supporting
militias in Iraq in Yemen and Lebanon
they're also highly sophisticated in
terms of their technical expertise they
have large numbers of Engineers with the
ability to develop weapons so you've
shown this contract to your sources what
are the ukrainians said about it they
said to me that they are working to find
out if it's authentic if it's credible
and if it is then they'll be looking to
take action and they said that they
found the contract extremely interesting
I've also shown it to our foreign
Secretariat he said he couldn't comment
on it immediately because obviously a
just shown it to him but he said that
the UK would be looking too to see if
they could confirm whether or not it was
credible again as well saying that they
would respond if it turns out that it is
authentic and he did also reiterate that
the UK has already issued sanctions many
times against Iran over its activities
including in terms of supporting Russia
when it comes to drones which is
something that the International
Community has widely condemned Iran over
and what about the Iranian and Russian
side well I've gone to the Iranian
embassy
Embassy to the Russian Embassy in London
to ask for a response about the
allegations that this contract exists
and the content of the contract I
haven't heard back from either of them
but if they do give a response then of
course we'll report that
[Music]
Russia has few allies in this war but I
guess one other they can rely on is the
Iranians for is your reporting suggests
material support but also in not
condemning the action that they're
carrying out in Ukraine that
relationship has only strengthened
following Russia's war in Ukraine with
Russia really needing Iran's support
that relationship is complicated because
Russia of course is on the side with
China the U.S the UK and other European
allies when it comes to trying to
contain Iran's nuclear weapons Ambitions
but at the same time seems happy to have
this relationship of convenience when it
comes to getting help from Iran to
support its war in Ukraine and the worry
is that as that relationship deepens
that perhaps Iran is going to be
benefiting more from the fact that
Russia is relying on it so much perhaps
and then what does that mean in terms of
what Iran can ask for in return it's
kind of historically fascinating to to
think that you know it would have been
the Soviets Who provided Iranians with
t-72 tanks back in the day and now after
the Russians start running short of
those the Iranians perhaps are offering
to uh return the favor in some way it
really does show that this relationship
between Russia and Iran is developing
for Russia you know it's clearly seeking
help from Iran as we know these
devastating suicide exploding drones
that Iran has provided have given Russia
the ability to attack Ukraine's air
defenses they've been using sort of a
mixture of Iranian drones and then also
their own long-range missiles to smash
Ukrainian cities especially Kiev in the
last few days in return we've previously
reported how Iran has received cash from
Russia for those drones not surprising
but also allegedly received captured
Western weapons Western weapons captured
on the battlefield in Ukraine sent by
Russia to Iran and the fear is that Iran
might be using these captured weapons
which include British anti-tank missiles
the enlaw to reverse engineer them and
then perhaps to advance their own
weapons capabilities through that kind
of exchange the sources that you've
spoken to it say that that is that is a
real concern that the Iranians could be
making us at NATO style weapons for use
on the battlefield against of course
Western enemy there's also a concern
about what kind of Technology Russia is
willing to share with Iran so this all
comes against the backdrop of Iran's
nuclear capabilities its desire
according to the west to develop nuclear
weapons there had been this
long-standing deal between Iran and a
group of countries including Russia so
Russia China the United States the UK
France months in Germany all together
trying to put pressure on Iran using
sanctions and other efforts to stop Iran
from developing nuclear weapons and Iran
has always insisted its nuclear
technology is only for civilian purposes
but remember that deal between those two
sides collapsed When Donald Trump was
President of the United States and the
concern of course underpinning all of
this is well nobody believes that Russia
wants to see a nuclear-armed Iran and
there's no sense of that being part of
this whatever assistance Russia is
giving to Iran when it comes to
technology that is a concern there are
sanctions against Iran heavy sanctions
from the Allies that are deliberately
designed to try to prevent Iran from
developing its nuclear capabilities and
so so as Iran is developing this
relationship with Russia in terms of
military exchanges then that's going to
be a concern not only for Western allies
but also in the region if Iran is
providing material support for Russia
and its war effort what kind of effects
could that have on other nations who
have a difficult relationship with the
West there's clear really like a sort of
globally isn't there there's like a
struggle going on over who is on whose
side the numbers that are openly and
actively supporting Russia are small and
they are typically more the Pariah State
like Iran and North Korea but yes
between those two spectrums there is
this pool of these non-aligned countries
many of whom do believe the false
Russian narrative that's pumped out
about the reasons behind the invasion of
Ukraine and look to the West with
disdain given Wars of the past like for
example the us-led invasion of Iraq and
sort of think of hypocrisy when the US
and the UK condemn what Russia is doing
in Ukraine so it is a difficult
um dilemma clearly there's loads of work
going on diplomatically to try to
convince and influence these non-aligned
countries including huge influential
countries like India for example that
actually Ukraine is on the right side of
history and countries should Ally with
Ukraine and absolutely condemn Russia
and there is the effort isn't there on
the part of the West the G7 at least I
know that the Indians and the Brazilians
were invited to the recent conference to
try and bring them across from the sort
of non-aligned column into the Ukrainian
support column especially for the UK
we've got such close ties with India it
clearly a difficult issue to have to
dance around the fact that India is you
know also closely allied with Russia
each individual country is going to be
thinking of its own national interests
and what benefits it the most when it
looks not just to the world as it is
right now but the world as it will be
going forward
balance of power globally is Shifting
and that's why when you hear politicians
like Joe Biden and Richie sunac talking
about this fight for democracy it really
is alive and the war in Ukraine is right
at the heart of that but it's not just
about Ukraine when it comes to that
struggle it's a global struggle and
countries are all having to make up
their own minds
[Music]
my thanks of course to Deborah Haynes
and to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Kamali Melbourne this
episode was produced by Annie Joyce the
editor is Philly Beaumont